bom dia
epá fosse precioso folia unia
isto é que é olha hoje trouxe os meus
dedos e vamos convidar fazer uma coisa
comigo é escolher a dois erros e
escolher quem quer fazer escolher dois
deles à frente e assim eu tenho aqui por
acaso o dinheiro que quem é o rapaz que
é masculino e também que outra que por
acaso é feminino é por acaso porque
podia ser também os dois rapazes
agora o que acontece com os dois terços
deles em frente o que aconteceu com o
rapaz e rapariga se vão dançar
o resto é treta quem acredite que está
ganhando masia som adulto obrigado é
verdade aqui estou contente aqui afinal
que estamos aqui com crianças e som
formador na área da educação não formal
e cada vez que fazer esta pergunta os
adultos a maioria disso o jogo o facto
está a magia muito boa mesmo muito boa e
eu dizem isso tipo comum como a
convenção forte sabendo que estão a
mentir sem vergonha nenhuma
este capacidade de mentir sem piscar
press
quase que se tornou uma fã me dizer uma
competência extraordinária dos adultos
então onde foi cursado os perderem a sua
inocência de criança
será que é o resultado de uma educação
torta deus será que é por aqui que saber
mentir é tornar no saudoso final ficando
pergunta
está no jô que ensina a bélgica é por
isso também que fala assim e tem uma
filha de 3 anos cama ajuda imenso a
serra dos mas o mais importante a
questionar o meia ser adulto e ajudaram
a ficar criança e gosto muito dessa
palavra criança porque sou muito orgulho
que ainda consegue pensar com mais
possível como criança cria ainda ser
mais com vocês hoje em dia a maior parte
ainda são
eu acho que isso tem portanto é criança
para mim significa muitas coisas
significa honestidade transparência
entusiasmo ela dizia às há um dinamismo
então pressionou bastante importante
intenção de ser criança identificar a
criança é ouvir muitas pessoas à volta
do im não gosto muito disto estou a
falar basicamente dos outros adultos e
sabe e eu acho que temos que ter muita
paciência com estadoso e quando vou
falar nos eu quero me referia que eu vou
fazer parte do vosso lado as crianças e
os adultos são outro lado também por
coisa que vamos ver aqui algumas coisas
sobre crianças e sobre o saudoso então
eu acho que tem o esterco e diz a
ciência começa o grupo a do sul e
principalmente com os nossos pais e não
sou um pouco paciência eu acho que um
monte de paciência porque é verdade que
ele ficar hoje em dia
tornou se um desafio gigante para muitos
deus também é verdade que ele cá já não
é tão fácil como por exemplo comer
bolacha o andar de bicicleta
o como já vi e vimos calcular a
distância até a total 11 é metros por
exemplo e também é verdade que isso
também tem uma história
muitos dos nossos pais e de certeza de
nossas avós tiveram uma infância
trabalhar talvez já falasse o ouvisse o
que eu vou falar nisso os teus pais
talvez também
é tão antigamente as crianças ajudava os
pais só pagar as contas
é verdade que hoje em dia já não é assim
que eu penso que muitos dos casos é bem
o contrário então é normal que os pais
muitos deles nunca tiverem um exemplo
claro o que é uma indicação adaptada
hoje em dia e se nos lembrarmos nos
lembra os meus pais muitas vezes estava
a dizer é olha o meu pai sempre dizia a
minha mãe sempre fazia e parece que às
vezes que estão a jogar connosco e este
é província as coisas acontecerem aos
durante a infância deus
então eu acho que o nosso missão com
crianças em nossa tarefa talvez é temos
a ajudar os nossos pais nossos ativos e
tias a tornar essa crianças coxilhas anp
troopas deste mundo e não só para jogar
mas também para tornar a nossa infância
um pouco mais agradável
então eu fiz aqui uma pequena pesquisa
o que eu acho que os pais têm aspectos
três aspectos que os pais têm muitas
vezes em comum
eu encontrei uma questão se as
repetições não necessários daqui a pouco
vamos ver o que significa o escudo foi
às perguntas de sempre eo terceiro às
contradições
talvez agora para fazer isso também vou
precisar um pouco vossa ajuda né
daqui a pouco vou vos mostrar algumas
frases da primeira as proteções
necessárias e quem reconheça esta frase
e só algumas das frases porém a frase
que os pais podem dizer tudo mais que
maior a sem parar há também quem diz é
pá já ouvi este franz disse assim ai ai
estamos pronto vou contar até 31 23
ai ai agora vamos fingir bem alto
o trecho muito bem atenção
vamos aqui o primeiro prazo quem manda
aqui sou eu não é difícil ter sito soft
que os teus pais às vezes dizem isso
desde aí também a avó segunda frase
enquanto e outros tentar fazer eu queria
mandar olha vou contar até três dias a
turma mal que ela lida com essa é uma
parte que existe em nosso favor como a
boca cheia
olha para mim quando fala contínuo
quando os outros falem as crianças cala
dizer aí está a ouvir o que estou a
dizer e dizer a verdade gosto ou não diz
a verdade isso é uma coisa estranha
porque isso nos traz de novo o início
nos conversa quem afinal a ensinou nos a
mentir
ali o time três anos e meio
os meus pais convencerem que existe o
pai natal também à fala 10 também o
coelho da páscoa e também a magia 14
ouros onde o arco-íris tocou o chão e
até que existem ela faz gordurosa
hidratá los
eu estava convencido que todos aqueles
que não acreditavam nesta coisas foram
os pobrezinhos neste mundo há muito
tempo e defende como uma imensa força
esta coisa que eu saí maravilhosas até
que descobri que tudo isto apenas estava
baseada em mentiras
eu posso tirar que fiquei muito chateado
e muito voltado a pensar então com que o
direito que basta os meus pais
agora estão a exigir de mim que diz a
verdade
não faz muito sentido às vezes para mim
também é verdade que temos dizer dizer a
verdade não tem nada a ver com fantasia
nem como instituição essa coisas bem
diferentes
então vamos aqui ver qual é a posição
crianças e adultos com 10
fomos então agora ver as perguntas
dezembro
a minha filha tem com o estresse muitas
vezes ignorada minha início espalhavam
um pouco eu acho que agora percebi os
porquês que ela ignora é que são as
minhas perguntas porque também sou pai
às minhas perguntas de sempre e olhando
atrás eu acho que ela tem razão vamos
aqui ver as perguntas que sempre faz a
minha filha faz tudo do misto bem tem
que ser
se eu fizesse xixi e cocô então para
minha filha é se perguntar se eu não
fazem sentido
então por que responderam
sou eu que tenho que saber não não ela
tem na face um tiro eu concordo porque
isso aí me lembrei daquele homem que
vive perto de dar cada vez cada dia que
eu vou lá fora ela faz as mesmas
perguntas mas cada dia as mesmas
perguntas também era notícia que o
cansaço
então vamos aqui ver se existem também
este pergunta sempre vossos pais vos
fazem aí a estamos pronto sim a atenção
como foi eu tenho de ir na escola
já fizeste os trabalhos da casa
já não basta o teu quarto limpas ter os
dentes
epá cansativo na cada dia as perguntas
de sempre
eu acho que falta aqui uma grande dose
de imaginação dos partos paz eu que é
verdade que nos com crianças
isto não nos falta ainda não e ainda bem
então fomos que ver qual é a posição
crianças adultos 20 e isso merece
começar a voltar mas para a criança já
duravam muito bem
o terceiro aspecto então já temos as
competições são necessárias
os perguntas de sempre e 80 são é igual
à que foi novo agora me esqueci aquela
palavra é muito difícil em português as
contradições óbvias muito bem obrigado
os pais e os mais querem que os filhos e
as filhas tenham um bom tempo é que
brinque e sejam felizes é que temos
novas experiências e que desenvolvam
novas competências mas depois estamos
sempre a ouvir o seguinte as
contradições jovens
ai ai ai vamos lá olha para tudo roupa
suja que chega vai limpar isto já te
disse para não correr
fique quieto e 60 e calada pois é mais
uma o fechado porque está sempre a
inventar novas coisas
este tribunal em um pouco então podemos
não podemos como é que é
eu acho que é hora certa e que nos
termos do mesmo ajudar os nossos pais na
nossa educação porque dizem que nós
somos o futuro crianças o futuro da
manhã o futuro também do grande do sul
então talvez também temos pensar em uma
educação adequada para futura da manhã
para nós agora é verdade que uma família
é como uma equipa
somos uma equipe em casa e como qualquer
equipa temos papéis diferença e
responsabilidades diferentes
eu acho que isso faz todo o sentido mas
os valores desta equipa devem ter as
mesmas por todas elas e nem só de lima
também é prática assim nós temos fazer
coisas acho que também os adultos devem
fazer essas coisas é ouvir o que os pais
sempre forma identificar coisas porque
ainda não sabemos tudo e percebemos tudo
mas também é verdade que nas crianças
só sabemos muitas coisas e mais
importante ainda sabemos ser criança e
fazer coisas com crianças
vamos primeiro ver também a posição
crianças adultos e 30 salva de palmas
agora essa conversa não é conversa para
começar aqui uma queda em casa né
também não é preciso fazer a mulher dele
mas talvez só tentar mudar algumas
coisas às vezes vale a pena dizer é hoje
à noite vai lá amanhã
desde o pai mãe avô então temos que
falar têm aqui algumas ideias sobre a
minha dedicação vamos aqui sentar e ver
o que é possível e já agora que estamos
tentado a ficar sentada porque também
que falar sobre o vosso reeducação e tem
alguém algumas propostas e temos pensar
como é que podemos chegar a um
carregamento em conjunto porque tudo
isso pode tornar o processo de ficar
mais fácil com menos tensão os menos
estresse confusões e também é importante
saber para os pais que estão cá cá a
participação verdadeira de cada um de
nós na vida social comunitária e
política começa de facto em casa
é ali que nós aprendemos como ser uma
dor diferente da nossa e se você está
pronto para este desafio
isto é a minha filha estava a ajudar com
isso é preciso que eles ou dar mais uma
coisa tem a ver com deus
e mais uma coisa que vamos ensinar que
vocês podem fazer hoje à noite com os
vossos pais para verificar se de fato
estão adultos perdidos ou ainda está um
pouco itu de criança lá dentro temos
deles assim está pronto para falar agora
o braço um dinheiro extra de dinheiro
vai entrar no braço e vai chegar até lá
em cima a atenção estava grávida magia
tá bem tá aqui com 23
o conseg
não é fazer isso hoje não está em casa
com os pais
olha boa sorte a tornar vos é adultos
o talvez não está obrigado